a few subpoenas landed at the US State
Department late Friday evening Congress
demanding documents and testimony from
five of their officials in the coming
days including the u.s. special envoy to
Ukraine ambassador Kurt Volker soon
after
volker quit his State Department job
this comes just after he and other Trump
administration officials were named by a
whistleblower in the complaint he
alleges the president cut off foreign
aid to Ukraine and days later in a phone
call asked the Ukrainian president for a
favor a promise to investigate Trump's
potential rival former Vice President
Joe Biden and his son hunter who once
had a seat on Ukrainian company board
now the US president is trying to turn
the tables releasing this ad accusing
Biden of being in the wrong
the prosecutors not fired do not get the
money Trump is accusing Biden of getting
a Ukrainian prosecutor fired for
investigating his son when in fact the
prosecutor was fired for not going after
corruption cases look in the weeks and
the months to come
is the Congress's job to pursue the
facts and the whole Donald Trump
accountable in the meantime my job our
job is to make sure above all else we
beat Donald Trump what does seem clear
is that after so many months of trying
to investigate not getting very far this
investigation is moving very fast so far
the administration has simply tried to
ignore Congress but now that impeachment
has been invoked if they take this case
to the courts precedent says they'll
likely forced the president to comply to
let aides testify to turn over all the
documents meaning it's possible a lot
more of what the president said
privately to many other world leaders
could become public and then the
Congress will have to decide if his
words rise to the level of impeachment
patty :
al Jazeera Washington